quand elle nous reçoit dans sa maison au
vert pré marianne bessat révèle de suite
toute son énergie et sa jovialité avec
son mari henri ils ont été très engagé
dans le milieu sportif entraîneur et
animateur de l'école de foot du verre
très à 85 ans elle est restée une femme
dynamique elle la pionnière qui à 53 ans
n'a pas hésité à bouleverser les codes
premiers sifflets je peux dire l'unique
sifflets que j'ai eu pendant toute la
durée au cours de la pièce j'ai arbitré
alors est ici encore on va essayer on
verra bien après ça n'a pas arrêté un
sifflet d'arbitré qu'elle obtient
officiellement le 8 mai 1966 désireuse
de bien maîtriser les règles du football
elle vient de réussir brillamment ses
examens techniques et pratiques
d'arbitrage à l'époque il n'ya que des
hommes en noir
aucune femme arbitre du coup la 3f la
fédération française est interpellé
alors qu'est ce qu'on fait de moi alors
ils ont beaucoup cogité là dessus mais
ils ont fini par admettre que je pouvais
en vitre et les jeunes minimes cadets
juniors mais il n'avait pas donné
l'autorisation pour les seniors pour la
protéger diront certains peut-être aussi
par méfiance sexiste mais marienne n'y
verra pas de malice et tiendra avec
passion et conviction son rôle on en
rythme il n'est pas question d'être
sévère ou des droits gentil on a huit
points et on applique les loin les
règles du jeu et c'est bon j'étais quand
même respecter lorsque je m'efforçais de
respecter tout le monde et tous les
joueurs sur le terrain
et puis il y aura des rencontres comme
celle avec un roi du ballon rond d'eau
amis
domi amigo à mon ami et la création d'un
trophée de football portant son nom et
plein de souvenirs soigneusement gardées
c'est la vraie première paire de
crampons que j'ai porté sa des 8 mai 66
moi j'aimerais que vous me parliez de
votre regard sur le football féminin
aujourd'hui femme arbitre un peu partout
et des joueuses alors je vais d'abord
parler non pas de l'arbitrage au féminin
arbitres âge reste un arbitrage mais les
joueuses parlons ça voilà leur wendy
renard à s'aimer c'est un bonheur de
gorge cette fille là et puis le football
féminin est plus plus agréable à
regarder
la plus de champ il est léger les filles
respecte les règles du jeu lés lois de
jeu sont impeccablement respecter
aujourd'hui la fff compte 1000 arbitres
féminines officiant tous niveaux
confondus
stéphanie fera par vient d'être la
première arbitre central en ligue 1 elle
est aussi retenu pour être l'arbitré
française pour le mondial féminin de
juin prochain
ce qui permet à marie anne b sert de
conclure c'est l'apothéose
sans peut être la prothèse